[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 3 octobre
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition les journées de recrutement et
hier à destination des jeunes saint
quentinois deux opérations se tenait sur
le territoire le scarabée à la verrière
accueillait un coup de pouce pour
l'emploi pour trouver un job dans le
même temps le service civique dating se
déroulait au théâtre national à montigny
le bretonneux des commotions cérébrales
en augmentation et la mort récente d'un
joueur de 21 ans à aurillac le rugby est
pointé du doigt pour la violence de ses
contacts à 14 mesures ont été annoncées
pour renforcer la sécurité de la
pratique de ce sport notamment pour les
jeunes dans ce journal reportage au sein
de l'école de rugby de versailles
et puis cette année marque la fin du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale tout au long des commémorations
des yvelinois ont participé à des
opérations autour du souvenir de la
grande guerre et les archives
départementales ont tenu à les remercier
avec une exposition deux invités
également à suivre dans ce journal
bertrand mesure du syndicat snu ipp et
des yvelines est les enseignants vont se
mobiliser le 9 octobre prochain et nous
recevrons également jean flattot des
amis du passé et d'elancourt pour parler
de la fête des vendanges qui fête cette
année un quart de siècle un contact
direct pour trouver un emploi la ville
de la verrière accueillait hier un job
dating organisé en partenariat avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et l'association rencontres
pour l'égalité d'accès à l'emploi
un coup de pouce pour l'emploi était
destiné aux 18 35 ans les précisions de
mélanie poker et yves hub stand berger
un contact direct et pas seulement par
courrier 18 entreprises et deux
organismes de formation ont participé à
ce job dating coup de pouce pour
l'emploi le deuxième organisé à la
verrière en début d'opération tous les
recruteurs se présente devant l'ensemble
des candidats déjà ça leur permet de
voir qu'ils vont avoir en face d'eux et
ensuite c'est une rencontre bas
qui fonctionne ou non mais on en dit
plus sur soi quand on rencontre une
personne qu'avec un simple cv auxiliaire
de vie agents de recouvrement
techniciens de maintenance
les postes proposés sont pour des débuts
de carrière sans qualification à bac + 2
j'aime bien voir autre chose ça lâche
quelqu un qui moi personnellement j'aime
bien essayer d'autres choses dans la vie
où je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant de démarcher dans ce genre
de concept parce que déjà les ceux qui
font les employeurs ils viennent
directement nous voir ils nous proposent
ils nous font un listing sur leurs
entreprises 92 jeunes de 18 à 35 ans se
sont présentées dans les yvelines les
moins de 49 ans était près de 50000 au
chômage au deuxième trimestre 2010 8
le réseau yvelines information jeunesse
lui donne rendez vous pendant tout le
mois d'octobre pour les jeunes en quête
d'un service civique
quatre événements service civique dating
sont programmées tout au long de ce mois
d'octobre dans le département le premier
était programmée hier au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
marylène iapichino et yves hub stand
berger depuis sa création en 2010 le
service civique a attiré plus de 260
mille jeunes volontaires pour continuer
sur cette lancée et faciliter les
rencontres entre recruteurs et
volontaire le réseau évident information
jeunesse leur a donné rendez vous pour
un speed dating du service civique
on a un grand nombre d'adhérents qui
nous sollicitent pour réaliser plein de
projets on n'est pas toujours assez
nombreux et justement le recrutement
aujourd'hui d'un service civique nous
permettrait de réaliser au mieux nos
missions collectivités ou associations
au total 22 structures se sont déplacés
pour proposer une centaine de missions
un dispositif apprécié par les jeunes
qui voudraient même le voir davantage
développés où on peut poser des
questions c'est plus rapide et puis
voit déjà l'enthousiasmé des personnes
également donc ça peut des fois motivé
plutôt que regarder sur le site internet
où là c'est vraiment du texte brut ça
que c'est dommage que ça n'ait pas été
assez développée au niveau de la partie
européenne et internationale plus
particulièrement n'a pas assez
d'association à ce niveau là en fait le
service civique peut durer de 6 mois 1
an et s'adresse à tous les jeunes entre
16 et 25 ans le tout est d'avoir du
temps libre et de la motivation pour
s'investir au minimum 25 heures par
semaine les jeunes qui s'investissent en
mission de service civique dans leur
parcours en fait ils sont à un stade où
ils se cherchent et wii peuvent
s'investir et donc c'est effectivement
les jeunes qui sont le plus éloignés de
l'emploi qui sont éventuellement aussi
sortis du système scolaire et pour qui
le service civique est un formidable
tremplin
reste désormais à poser les bonnes
questions pour trouver sa mission idéal
chaque jeune ne peut réaliser qu'un seul
service civique au cours de sa vie
aujourd'hui à mercredi l'opération se
tenait à achères demain à l'investir à
aubergenville dernier sir avis civique
dating de la semaine ce samedi à
rambouillet journée de grève mardi
prochain plusieurs syndicats appellent à
une mobilisation interprofessionnelle
pour protester contre l'action du
gouvernement dans le cortège il y aura
aussi le monde enseignant bonsoir
bertrand mesure lancement vous êtes co
secrétaire du syndicat snui pp et des
yvelines c'est un syndicat des
enseignants du premier degré on va
dresser avec vous le bilan de cette
rentrée dans les yvelines première
question pourquoi vous mobiliser le 9
octobre
parce que si pendant le précédent
gouvernement il y avait eu un effort qui
avait été fait pour compenser la saignée
qui avait été mise en place par le
gouvernement de ce qu'ils sarkozy depuis
que monsieur macron est arrivé on est
clairement sur une pente qui va amener
petit à petit une dégradation très
significative du service public il ya le
gouvernement qui annonce est tout de
même une hausse récente du budget pour
l'éducation nationale 750 millions
d'euros supplémentaires c'est une hausse
en fait c'est une hausse comptable mais
qui en fait se traduit par une
diminution en euros constants de ce qui
va être effectivement donné aux écoles
puisque pour faire simple il ya toute
une partie de transfert de budgets qui
était assuré auparavant par d'autres
ministères comme par exemple les
contrats aidés qui vont maintenant peser
sur l'éducation nationale et quand on
fait la somme de ces transferts
on épuise très rapidement les 750
millions donc on va se retrouver vers un
budget de disette
alors il ya quelques jours vous
présenter le bilan de cette rentrée dans
les yvelines avec vos collègues aussi
notamment du second degré il ya eu
depuis cette rentrée des mobilisations
et blocages d'enseignants dans le
département est ce que vous diriez que
cette rentrée s'est faite sous tension
alors la rentrée s'est faite sous
tension pour une raison assez simple
c'est que l'idée du gouvernement de
mettre en place des classes dédoublées
en éducation prioritaire qui est une
bonne idée se fait au détriment des
autres classes que ce soit en éducation
prioritaire ou hors éducation
prioritaire
donc on se retrouve avec des effectifs
très chargé une tension un peu partout
et c'est ce qui fait que les collègues
actuellement sont particulièrement
remontés s'y ajoute le fait que le
gouvernement souhaite mettre un pilotage
par l'évaluation pilotage par
l'évaluation qui s'est mis en place dans
des par exemple en suède ou dans les
pays anglo-saxons et qui a démontré
toute la noce au cifit et qu'il y avait
pour l'école et pour les personnels donc
tout ça ce sont des points 2-2 colère
chez nos collègues et qui souhaitent le
manifester ce constat elle est également
dressé par vos collègues du second degré
dans le second degré on assiste à une
déréglementation complète du bac qui se
traduit par l'ensemble des réformes qui
ont eu lieu d'abord au collège puis au
lycée qui font que à terme le bac ne
sera plus un diplôme national que
l'organisation des services dans les
lycées devient une vrai casse tête et
que même les proviseurs les corps
d'encadrement l'ensemble des personnels
de l'éducation nationale ce qui est très
rare commencent à pointer un problème à
la fois de méthodes et à fois un
problème de personne il faut bien dire
monsieur blanc caire et dans une vision
extrêmement idéologique de l'école qui
ne correspond pas à ce qui se passe au
quotidien sur le terrain
le premier degré vous en parliez le
dossier de la rentrée c'était la suite
de cette mise en place des classes
dédoublées débuter l'an passé dans le
réseau d'éducation prioritaire lors
cette année ce dispositif a été étendu
à l'ensemble des cp du réseau
d'éducation prioritaire à certains ces
vins ça concerne en tout trois cent
quarante sept classes dans les yvelines
le principe c'est bien sûr d'avoir ces
douze élèves pour un suivi personnalisé
plus personnalisé est ce que un an après
ses premières expérimentations la suite
de cette mise en place vous êtes vous
êtes satisfait de cette mesure où
faut-il encore l'améliorer évidemment
satisfait d'une mesure qui vise à
diminuer les effectifs en particulier
dans les zones les plus difficiles
c'est quelque chose que nous réclamons
depuis très longtemps mais on pourrait
s'interroger pourquoi les cp et les ce1
pourquoi pas non plus à l'école
maternelle qui est un moment essentiel
pour apprendre et veiller au détriment
d'autres classes voilà et de toute façon
c'est au détriment des autres classes y
compris en éducation prioritaire quand
vous évoquez le chiffre de 12,7 un
chiffre théorique et dans beaucoup
d'endroits ça se traduit par des classes
qui sont à 13 14
et quand on regarde sur les élèves de
cycle 3 on se retrouve avec des classes
qui frôle les 27 élèves en éducation
prioritaire
et je ne parle même pas de leur
éducation prioritaire ou la tension là
est à son maximum
la promesse de 12 élèves pour l'instant
pas tenu la promesse de 12 élèves n'est
pas formellement tenue mais en plus ça
se fait au détriment des autres classes
alors quid des locaux également vous
inquiétez également chez nos confrères
du manque de locaux notamment à trappes
ou vous renseigner ou les capacités
maximales en termes de locaux souvent
sont déjà atteintes
elles sont déjà atteintes donc ce qui
fait que les écoles ont dû épuiser
l'ensemble des salles qui étaient
disponibles par exemple pour une
bibliothèque pour une salle informatique
etc
l'année prochaine si on prend l'exemple
de trappes que vous évoquez il n'y a
plus de places de disponibles donc
clairement la montée en puissance sur
les ce1 sur une partie des écoles se
fera avec 24 25 26 27 élèves par classe
avec deux anciennes ont certes mais ce
sera toujours avec 24 et 27 élèves
on est quand même loin de ce qui était
annoncé d'autant plus que le
gouvernement ne s'est pas soucié en
amont de ces annonces de savoir si les
locaux étaient disponibles je précise
juste pour être complet sur ce dossier
que daniel filâtre recteur de l'académie
de versailles a promis un dédoublement
fixe pour tous avant la fin de l'année
revenons juste à cette mobilisation du 9
octobre que réclamez-vous
au gouvernement ce qu'on réclame
clairement c'est que enfin on s'occupe
de l'école et que on s'occupe pas de
faire passer dans l'école des
présupposés idéologiques en matière de
lecture en matière de formation on est
clairement sur une vision utilitariste
de l'école pour le plus grand nombre et
une vision élitiste pour quelques-uns
est ce que vous savez si cette
mobilisation sera suivie et si vous êtes
déjà un ordre d'idée
comment elle sera suivie dans l'horreur
que tôt pour le savoir on espère qu'elle
sera suivie et d'ailleurs nous avons
déjà mis dans en perspective un autre
mouvement pour le 12 novembre
merci bertrand mesure d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le co
secrétaire du syndicat snu ipp et des
yvelines changer les regards et donner
l'opportunité aux personnes vivant avec
un handicap mental de s'épanouir par le
sport c'était l'objectif de la course
solidaire interentreprises spécial
olympique ce rendez vous désormais
habituel à l'occasion de la semaine du
handicap à montigny le bretonneux l
événement fêté hier ça est 10ème édition
le principe un relais 4 x 2 5 km 150
salariés des alentours représentant 14
entreprises y ont participé
micros tendus sur la ligne d'arrivée par
yves hub stand berger et c'est bien
c'est un esprit de compétition et ça
j'aime bien ça j'aime bien participer
un peu dur mais ça a laissé monter ouais
j'ai passé un très bon moment
ouais c'est ça les uns c'était
l'ambiance il était bien ok c'est
important de personnes en situation de
handicap et qu'elles puissent s'épanouir
à travers le sport tout au long de
l'année et la totalité de la recette de
la course sera reversée à l'association
à l'association a special olympics
france pour deux nouveaux événements
le rugby a entamé sa mue avec à 14
mesures annoncées par le président de la
fédération française bernard laporte
c'était le 15 septembre dernier
objectif renforcer la sécurité de la
pratique de ce sport où les commotions
ont augmenté de 35 % en deux ans dans le
championnat de top 14
cet après midi à un député a d'ailleurs
interpellé la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn sur ce sujet ces dispositions
s'ajoute au toucher 2 secondes déjà
mises en place en ile de france depuis
plusieurs années notamment à versailles
un reportage de nicolas landry défendre
en touchant son adversaire et lui
laisser deux secondes pour faire une
passe c'est la nouvelle règle mise en
place dans les écoles de rugby et
notamment ici au rugby-club de
versailles une disposition en oeuvre
depuis quatre ans en ile-de-france pour
favoriser un style de jeu et sécuriser
les joueurs le but c'est d'inciter par
la règle à faire évoluer le jeu donc
c'est du rugby à toucher
donc avec continuité du jeu touché deux
secondes touché avec ballons donnés au
contact aujourd'hui c'est repris par la
fédération française au niveau des
écoles de rugby et aujourd'hui ce qui se
rajoutent ont plus effectivement c'est
le passage en force qui pour des raisons
sécuritaires quand un défenseur est
arrêté ça peut être un peu plus
dangereux donc ça c'est une donnée
supplémentaire qui sécurise l'ensemble
du jeu de rugby
recherchez les espaces s'en allait
obligatoirement au contact
l'enseignement de données par les
éducateurs à versailles tout en
préparant aux plaquages les petits
rugbymen dès le plus jeune âge avec
cette volonté d'éviter les chocs
violents
ce jeu de mouvement ça a un intérêt dans
science une porteur de balle va chercher
à éviter les défenseurs à avancer dans
les intervalles et donc à ne pas rentrer
dans les murs comme on peut voir sur
certaines vidéos de pro on apprend sur
le plaquage par exemple a bien passé sa
tête sur le côté avec la tête calée sur
la fesse qui est molle pour ne pas
justement se faire mal donc en fait on
apprend plusieurs mouvements qui nous
met en sécurité les enfants à versailles
et les moins de 8 ans joue à l'épervier
adapté au rugby le but ne pas se faire
rattraper en traversant le terrain c'est
quand même un jeu quelconque effet pour
le contournement
donc c'est assez intéressant dans le
sens où nous nous ce qu'on recherche
c'est à éviter l'adversaire alors après
il ya ce qu'il y à cette notion
plaquages mais qui est quand même
importante dans le rugby parce qu'on
fait vraiment un sport qui en a besoin
un sport qui attire toujours autant les
petits versailles et l'école de rugby
compte près de 250 licenciés chaque
saison sur ces dernières années on
reparlera à sport à la fin de cette
édition avec un tournoi de pétanque à
reportage sur un tournoi de pétanque en
2013 les archives départementales des
yvelines lancé plusieurs opérations
collaborative autour de la première
guerre mondiale plus de 7000 personnes
au total y ont pris part des anonymes
travaillant pour la plupart derrière
leur ordinateur pour les remercier elle
les archives situe à montigny le
bretonneux ont créé une exposition les
mettant à l'honneur
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 17
novembre mélanie poker le sourire est
timide voire gêné catherine chevalier
n'est pas modèle mais l'une des petites
mains de testament de poilus un des
projets collaboratifs des archives
yvelinoise je préparais une exposition
pour ma ville parce que je m'occupe
d'une association de généalogie
d'histoire locale donc je voulais
retrouver le plus d'informations
possibles sur les poilus de ces villes
d'aubergenville et donc comme de toute
façon j'allais piocher dans les archives
et faire des recherches je me suis dit
autant que ce soit utile aussi à
d'autres personnes et donc va chercher
les testaments poilus pour pour le
projet des marchés départemental comme
catherine une vingtaine de participants
a accepté de se prêter au jeu
ils donnent de leur temps pour recenser
les poilus compléter un wiki ou
décrypter des testaments
avec cette exposition les archives
départementales met en lumière lors 7000
bénévoles
c'est vraiment mettre une identité
derrière les contributeurs dans notre
travail au quotidien on parle de notre
équipe de contributeurs parce qu'on a
quand même un vivier assez important de
personnes très impliquées très présentes
qui participent beaucoup et puis
finalement comme beaucoup de projets
sont en ligne via des plateformes
informatiques
ce sont des noms des pseudos et on a pas
on les voit pas finalement capturé par
l'objectif de tirer mouny le photographe
des archives les portraits sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre une
grande journée fait de l'histoire
conclure à l'exposition le rendez-vous
est toujours pris au début de l'automne
il fête cette année un quart de siècle
ce dimanche c'est la 25e édition de la
fête des vendanges à la ferme du
mousseau d'elancourt c'est un événement
organisé par l'association des amis du
passé d'elancourt avec nous en plateau
son président jean flattot bonsoir ce
moment alors cette fête des vendanges
c'est toujours un rendez vous que vous
attendez avec impatience chaque année
oui attendu par les membres de
l'association les amis du procès en
cours mais aussi les enfants et les
habitants d'el en cours et des communes
voisines qui peuvent venir vendanger qui
sont invités puisque les vendanges sont
toujours gratuites et qui existe depuis
25 ans toujours le premier dimanche
d'octobre
cette association des amis du passé
d'elancourt vous l'avez créé en 1987
c'est quoi ces missions c'est alors
cette association je côtoyais de
nombreux jeux faisait partie de
plusieurs associations l'époque sur les
transports sur la défense de l'habitat
et j'ai côtoyé un certain nombre de
personnes que j'ai regroupé qui j'ai
demandé pour pouvoir justement faire
créer une association les amis du passé
dans kof qui avait pour but que ce soit
pédagogique ludique puis toujours festif
est donc en affreux créé plusieurs
événements et à l'époque 87 ses deux
deux années avant 89 et c'était pour
préparer les fêtes du bicentenaire de
1989 auxquelles nous avons participé
mais également faire des recherches et
transmettre nous avons fait plusieurs
livres le premier élan corp et sans
décoller l'épreuve et le troisième est
un deuxième sur la vigne qui épuise il
met le troisième elancourt un village
devenue ville avec lequel montrer donnez
le moi je veux montrer des images donc
celui-là
voilà donc voilà ces livres que avec
lesquels vous êtes venu en plateau alors
vous disiez association qui a pour but
voilà de promouvoir ces événements
festifs pédagogique ludique
il ya beaucoup d'enfants à chaque fois
cette fête des vendanges chaque année
pour moi c'est important pour vous cette
transmission
alors d'abord pourquoi une vigne mais il
faut savoir que le plus grand vignoble
il ya cent ans avant le phylloxéra
c'était l'île de france
il y avait pratiquement des vignes dans
tous les villages dans l'ancienne cdo
aux puisque les yvelines font partie de
l'ancienne salle des oiseaux au
moyen-âge à des vignes avait des vignes
et monsieur stefan avait fait pour
justement le deuxième livre histoire de
la vigne il encourt ont ils avaient
retrouvé un certain nombre d'éléments et
des noms de rues des propriétaires il ya
eu tout un travail d'archivés et puis
c'est aussi le but de l'association
transmettent et transmettent par
l'intermédiaire de livres mais je
pourrai plus longue manque dire ce qui
est du parce que là on a eu des
événements très importants en
particulier il ya un
bombardier lancaster qui était tombé sur
il encourt abattu par un avion allemand
de la nuit du 10 au 11 juin 1944 et nous
avons retrouvé on l'avait beaucoup de
chance les descendants de trois des sept
aviateurs et puisqu'il y avait deux
australiens dans le pilote cette
deuxième mission de canadiens trop
brutale
il faut pas se tromper deux écossais un
anglais et nous avons cueilli à 4 ans il
ya une stèle dans le parc des coudrais
la commune il ya un partenariat avec la
mairie d'elancourt pour cet événement
mais j'en cite un travail très très
fouillée par vos membres et les membres
des années que j'ai passées des droits
au travail collectif
à quoi ressemble et les quelques jours
qui précèdent cette fête des vendanges
comment préparez vos vignes à la récolte
alors nous avons eu de la chance
pas de grêle pas de gel mais comme
chaque année plus ou moins il y à des
maladies les maladies sont ces
liquidations les clones tomates sur les
courgettes à savoir médium mildiou est
en fait une année sur l'autre il peut y
avoir plusieurs mois bonne récolte est
jeune nous avons une équipe parmi les
amis du passé des personnes qui nous ont
rejoint sous la houlette de joseph
gonthier qui est le nôtre maître de chai
chef vigneron qui a fait un travail et
avec une réunion hebdomadaire
c'est-à-dire pioche et biner des pieds
ensuite c'est la bonne récolte alors
cette année si on table sur les
vignobles danton a vu qu'ils sont
vendangés actuellement ça devrait être
une année exceptionnelle est très tardif
puisque ça va être le 7 octobre
très concentré en sus que nous avons eue
le collège de guyancourt cas venu
visiter des élèves et qui ont pu voir
tout ce travail qui est en effet
d'entretien de la vigne est de préparer
et là normalement il ya de belles
grappes de raisin avec des hybrides pour
éviter les maladies quelques pieds de
chardonnay un savagnin que j'avais
essayé
pourquoi je suis franc comtois et de
savagnin c'est un cépage de
franche-comté l'équivalent de d'arbois
et commence à se dérouler les vendanges
de la récolte le pressage à lanus et
depuis début d'accord c'est des
vendanges gratuite pour les enfants pour
les parents ou vient d'elancourt et des
environs de france et de navarre et là
en fait les gamins à l'ancienne ils
coupent des raids des grappes de raisin
ensuite ces grappes de raisins sont mis
dans un fouloir pour fouler avec les
pieds donc les gamins dégâts mais une
foule avec des pieds on jette ce 1er
juin petit peu puis ensuite il est
grappe avec un des grands ports du
raisin le raisin ensuite pressés is
angle il s'autorisait déguster avec des
parents le jus de raisin qui va être
très sucré je suis sûr et qui fait déjà
des degrés d'alcool peut-être pas loin
de 10 cette année et ils ont un goûter
gratuit offert par les amis du passé et
ensuite il ya la commune nous prête un
camion qui est décoré le samedi qui
précède en forme de shore pour ensuite
vendanges terminées la police accompagne
de camions le char le cortège au vidage
dans l'ancienne mairie école soit dans
la course il fait beau ce soit sous le
préau et l'ail un repas dansant animé
par la country et de line ligne c'est à
dire dans ce groupe qui vont étape pour
faire des démonstrations et faire danser
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter on arrive
déjà à la fin de cet entretien pour
cette 25e fête des vendanges et bien
quel que soit le temps que tout le monde
vienne et le lendemain tout est prêt
c'est pour faire du jus de raisin et
mettant en tonneaux ensuite bien et donc
cette 25e fête des vendanges rappelle
malaisie oui il ya juste annoncé déjà
dès le 2 décembre
deuxième salon du livre en partenariat
mairie et sky et là l'année dernière
c'était un succès dans la commanderie
des templiers
il ya eu entre 10 800 et 2000 personnes
présentes et donc on est déjà sûr
bouquet avec le nombre d'auteurs c'est
l'évènement suivant c'est un autre grand
rendez vous organisé par l'asa vincent
le 2 février 2019
la fête des vignerons et le premier
rendez vous qui arrive c'est donc dès ce
dimanche la 25e fête des vendanges et je
rappelle cette organisé dis par votre
association les amis du passé
d'elancourt merci jean flatté d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup
allez on referme ce journal avec de la
pétanque une manche du championnat
départemental était organisée dimanche
dernier à trappes et des boulistes venus
d'elancourt de houdan ou encore de
maurepas se sont affrontés toute la
journée
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
yves hub stand berger on a tiré et on a
pointé à trappes sous un soleil quasi
estival la commune accueilli ce week-end
le championnat départemental de pétanque
au terrain rené calque un rendez vous
attendu par les puristes illinois comme
l encours à des amis mais compétition
c'est vraiment la compétition
au programme aujourd'hui un championnat
triplettes mixtes avec deux boules pour
chaque joueur présent pour réussir à
remporter la victoire tous les boulistes
ou leurs techniques pour bien jouer dans
tous les cas même si on sait on joue un
peu moins les gens un peu moins moins
fort on va dire faut dans tous les cas
il faut jouer ces boules s'appliquer à
rester concentré toujours sa demande du
mental ça demande de la patience il faut
être diplomate fair play et avec les
adversaires
ça demande aussi avoir de l'endurance au
niveau physique parce qu'on en fait des
kilomètres dans une journée
faut être adroit
la journée s'est ensuite terminée par un
pique nique géant entre tous les
participants
c'est aussi ça l'ambiance pétanque c'est
la fin de ce journal dans un instant
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat qui
reviendra sur les inquiétudes autour des
compteurs électriques linky belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]